Today, I'm working together with my sponsors, Holiday Inn Express,...
...to show you some of my favorite traveling hacks.
If you're packing shoes, you can wrap them in a shower cap.
This will help stop your clothes from getting dirty.
And if you like, you can drop a couple of tea bags inside...
...to keep them smelling fresh.
A hoodie doubles up as a great laptop protector.
Place your laptop in the middle and fold it over like this.
Tuck it all inside the hood and cross the arms over.
This should fit neatly inside your case and keep your laptop well-protected.
If you're packing for a quick overnight stay,...
...you can fold some underwear and a t-shirt like this,...
...lay some socks on top and roll it all up.
Then fold your socks over and tuck it all in...
...to make a neat, self-contained clothes bundle,...
...which will fit straight into your shoulder bag...
...and is perfect for an overnight stay.